greetings I'm Curtin Davina and this is
our 2020 predictions first up we're
gonna talk to Jake Jake what's your
20/20 prediction don't be in this video
max you look available was your 20/20
prediction Ben 10 Gingka
what is your 20/20 prediction uh
PhotoPass two for smash is gonna be one
buck bumble and for cosmic use next
Sherman uh sonic immunity to launch
title for ps5 that's the the Alessandro
what is your petition for 2020 fallout 7
new six will finally be a good game in
2020 that's very wholesome and
optimistic of you thank you for that
Matthew Jarek Alessandra Spinelli I know
it's not gonna have a mother three is
coming didn't too much I have a sweet
dreams sort of a [ __ ] anyways Jordan so
Michael 2020 prediction my good friend
Jacob Decker is gonna quit screwing
around and embrace his love for anime
2020 gang game sorry sir no anime
allowed Erte is there anything you think
what happen in 2020
not really no nothing end of the world
hey Randy what are your 20/20 prediction
hey John
was it 20/20 prediction David that's not
even a prediction dude can't tell anyone
all right Keanu Reeves he's gonna be in
a video game John Luke 2020 prediction
that's not gonna happen
Lucy Lucy what do you think is gonna
happen I think in 2020 there will be
full cross-platform play PlayStation
Microsoft PC that's ambitious and
believable and sweet I don't think is
gonna happen Jesse Jesse chesty what's
your 20/20 prediction if the question is
whether there are ducks in the UK there
are I just looked it up I did research
and there are ducks in the UK why can't
you just add this sweet boy to sword and
shield please do it do it Ryan would and
well you heard it here a lot of sincere
truthful predictions for 2020 from the
very respectable GameSpot staff which I
think all those things are going to come
true
anyways here's look into 2020 there are
many ducks in the UK the mail tough
deduct the female tough to duck the
mallard there are so many these could be
gallery' and ducks these are good boys
and girls and they should be in the game
and you should add them because I love
them very much
I don't understand why you've done this
to me I don't understand I've given you
everything pokemon it given you
everything folk about